[Music]
welcome to the 11th annual 60-70 contest
we are doing the live web broadcast
robots begin on either end of the table
on these starting areas from this point
on the robots are on their own and then
they have 60 seconds to operate there
are 18 of these yellow balls laying on
the table these are worth two points to
any robot that possesses them there are
balls in each of these robots the object
is to get those balls into the hole all
right and there huh you won they've got
that amazing strategy you've got all
sorts of those
look at that Wow that's pretty fast we
need to see nothing interesting as you
can see they're dropping all the balls
on it this is a really high scoring
robot you can see how much of just so
the wiring nightmare begins to get oh
please about the job and of course the
crowd is yelling forth to jump somehow
your robot gets that performance anxiety
will stage right up there we're like two
cores 14 and of course 10 major so we
knew we had no chance
[Applause]
we still have four robots in the in the
front of route so main strategies just
in six balls and trying to extract out
robots before it gets any points it
looks like one of the balls might drop
in the hollow
finals for Team 2728 points
so we tried to do line following and
that just didn't work so then back to
the simplest thing we could think of and
there it is
loading up dog people bringing their
friends and they're all what kind of dog
do you think those would be
interesting team one wins 12 to 4
general Gao is a good name for two
reasons one I like general Gao chicken
and 2 general Gao is a name which
inspires fear and respect in our
opponents
alright looks like dog just cleaned up
or just wait for general God to do its
thing
alright there's two balls in one mole
that general Gao just dropped all of his
balls like
final score team won 22 points team 27
14 points
three and a half beats of work have come
the culmination and we we now have a
winner team one sayonara see you next
year see you next year
[Applause]
welcome to the 11th annual 6270 contest
we are doing the live web broadcast
robots begin on either end of the table
on these starting areas from this point
on the robots are on their own and then
they have 60 seconds to operate there
are 18 of these yellow balls laying on
the table these are worth two points to
any robot that possesses them there are
balls in each of these robots the object
is to get those balls into the hole
all right and there huh you won they've
got that amazing strategy you've got all
sorts of those
look at that Wow that's pretty fast we
need to see that's an interesting
strategy you can see they're dropping
all balls on it it's still really high
scoring robot you can see how much of
just so the wiring nightmare begins to
get oh we got someone on the edge there
he's about to jump and of course the
crowd is yelling for it to jump somehow
your robot gets that performance anxiety
will stage right up there we're like to
course 14 and of course 10 major so we
knew we had no chance
[Applause]
we still have four robots in the in the
final round so main strategies just
getting six balls and trying to extract
our robots before it gets any points
it's like one of the boss might drop in
the Hollow
final score team 27 28 points
[Applause]